[Music]
as we head into the day of day in vegas
weekend we're getting an update on the
astro world tragedy discussing artist
and promoter liability with eric
palacios the sponsors of this next
segment
check it out hey eric welcome back
thanks for having me
unfortunately we have to discuss astro
world because today we heard there was a
ninth death at the concert festival so
let's just talk about the liability here
um you know are the artists and
promoters of these shows liable for
injuries and deaths unfortunately
it depends generally no
because on the back of your ticket uh
you will have a disclaimer that says
you're participating in an activity that
is inherently danger and you may suffer
injury or even death so in order for
there to be liability uh you have to
show extreme negligence on the part of
the artist the venue the promoter or
even recklessness and of course at
astroworld travis scott shows they're
known for those mosh pits so coming up
for day in vegas this weekend you know
what should what should people know
about sufficient negligence um via the
artist or the promoters
well the artists the promoters the venue
needs to know what type of show they're
putting on if they're going to have a
mosh pit if they know people are going
to get excited and jump around and push
and shove if it's a tough crowd then
they need to have adequate measures in
place that being security uh that being
levels of filling the venue sometimes
leaving some empty spaces uh just so
they can compensate for that uh extra uh
anxious crowd so it's important for the
people to know who their audience is
going to be and take the necessary
precautions any advice for concertgoers
you know especially for this weekend
yes we know a lot of people come to
vegas some venues or concerts or
hundreds of thousands for some festivals
basically know where you're at at all
times if you see the artist coming up is
one of those that generates a lot of
intensity and you don't want to be in
the middle of it take a step back always
be aware of your surroundings don't get
caught in the middle of something that
you don't feel comfortable in or that
can be a danger to your health so just
important to always be around your group
of friends and be aware of what's going
on around you absolutely follow that
intuition and keep your eyes and ears
open right
that's it be safe out there
be safe out there number one for more
information give eric palacios and
associates a call at 702-444-7777